[Music]
okay today we are talking welcome to
digging this we were talking about how
Bernie Sanders got ultimately [ __ ] by
himself oh I don't know anything so how
do you I have tried to keep everyone up
to date on all Bernie Sanders news did
he put superglue in his hairspray well
you've been here for some of the
conspiracy corners but I have tried to
keep everyone abreast not me not me
either no no on what's going on with
Bernie and how the DNC has been [ __ ]
burning hard yes exact phrase the
conclusion of this journey where Bernie
has once again and I predicted this to
many people privately I'm like guess
what Bernie's gonna let himself get
[ __ ] I actually said this on Jake it
is I was like he won't defend himself he
doesn't defend his ideals and so
therefore he's going how is he not
defending his ideas is the first couple
like what are your not primaries for the
Democratic debates like I felt like he
was doing a pretty good job early on
right what happened and I and I just
kind of stopped watching he never called
the DNC for doing what they did to him
in 2016 he never called them at one time
but this would that help him yes yes
there's a base of people who can't wait
to maybe he doesn't want to get suicided
oh there's a Clinton there's a base of
people who can't wait to [ __ ]
boyfriend come no they can't wait to
push at the DNC from the left okay
there's a lot of people on the
progressive side who cannot wait to
actually go to the NCN be like yo you
guys are not approaching any of this
[ __ ] from the side that we're on which
is like we want things to be done from a
liberal perspective the DNC does things
from a neo liberal perspective which is
basically in line with a neo
conservative perspective which is why
this guy named Rick Wilson who is this
[ __ ] ex Romney guy is in completely
in line with how the Democrats feel
today like a David Axelrod or any these
guys like X Obama he's the X Obama
campaign manager
okay so a lot of these guys are in line
with each other because they all agree
on war they all agree on the way that we
bail out Wall Street they all agree on
the way that we do taxes all the things
that we do right now they're all in line
together
and so the basic idea is that the DNC
seems content to lay down and let Trump
win again instead of actually fronting a
candidate like a Bernie who could
actually potentially put up a fight so
they're putting up a Biden in place
because they know that Biden is
controllable look at the guy he's
[ __ ] senile I don't know anybody who
thinks that Biden's type I never met one
person who's like Obama people they say
want Obama endorses bite and I like
publicly said yes he already has yeah
then the Biden's gonna get the
Democratic vote look he's already
getting it it's fine but the point being
I don't know anyone who's enthusiastic
about Biden who's like it's another
Clinton situation absolutely I can't
wait to get Joe Biden in there he's
actually worse than Clinton because
Clinton there's a famous video of her on
September 11th where she got dizzy yeah
fell into a van okay Joe Biden is like
that every day
not on September 11th Joe Biden you see
the video of him last night or it was a
it was three nights ago Joe Biden gives
his victory speech and then he freezes
up at the end and his wife has like okay
honey let's go and then he's like yeah
like you know right exactly that's what
this is all being set up the DNC is
completely content with Trump winning
again rather than running somebody who
could beat yeah
because it's all about the money right
if you can run an email campaign every
week saying here's what's wrong dude
[ __ ] you this week then a bunch of
people donate from that and then
everyone gets pissed collectively and
you run you donate a bunch of money and
the DNC's coffers get filled and the
DNC's and a lot of debt right now
they're perfectly content with you doing
that arena
[Music]
hey well it's always gonna be like that
but really cuz Spears according to me is
just [ __ ] talking about the real [ __ ]
that's going on because I can show you
that that the DNC [ __ ] Bernie and then
people still call that conspiracy [ __ ]
it's not conspiracy Shane show acting on
a Brazil the the former head of the DNC
admitted to doing this [ __ ] and I've
talked about this [ __ ] before but I have
to reiterate this [ __ ] because everyone
look look okay I've talked to how many
times have I talked about the Russian
[ __ ] I said Oh russian collusions
what's a [ __ ] I told that to you
years ago guess what it turns to be
[ __ ] oh guess what you might say oh
yeah but there was a bunch of
indictments that the Justice Department
levied down against all these Russian
actors who were trolling on the [ __ ]
guess what the DOJ just dumped that
yesterday oh you might say bill bar he
thuggin he's in cahoots with Trump and
he purposely made sure that they dumped
the case no no no
Muller's own prosecutors signed off on
dumping the case which means they had
[ __ ] nothing they didn't expect the
Russian trolls to go to trial because it
was all optical it was a campaign being
[ __ ] initiated against the Trump
administration so we wouldn't talk about
the real [ __ ] and the real [ __ ] is [ __ ]
like what Bernie's talking about we're
like you guys can't afford health care
right now isn't that interesting see
this is where it's like truth is
stranger than fiction it's like so crazy
that it's like people don't want to
believe it because they'd rather they'd
rather believe something [ __ ] they'd
rather believe that you know something
[ __ ] up that makes more sense in that
their government is conspiring against
them or whatever hey look I'm just one
of those [ __ ] who's like wow isn't
it cool that our government can bail us
all out during economic down climb but
why can't they bail us all out when we
all can't afford health care yeah and
that's all that's all I'm saying right
so so [ __ ] the the whole thing that we
all have to it's like oh why can't we
figure out how to make it financially
work all the [ __ ] the media always asks
Bernie like how financially how can you
make that work and Bernie's like well
you know we can print money we can just
watch
we can do but everyone's always so full
of [ __ ] about that because everyone
seems to think that it all needs to add
up but at the end of the day we keep
running a deficit up with China nobody
cares
like why is that and so that's that's
all that the people on the Bernie side
are saying is like if you can print
money for this why can't you print money
for the people who were actually
affected by all this [ __ ]
and so I get called out all the time
people are like well so Steve seems to
be down with all the [ __ ] no I'm down
I'm down with what I agree with a lot of
what Bernie's talking about it's just
it's just that it sucks that Bernie's
the messenger because Bernie lays the
[ __ ] down and lets everyone run all over
him and doesn't seem to care about his
voters he never stuck up for himself and
was like hey this is [ __ ] up he
instead just allows everyone to run all
over him and go to the DNC he lets he
let's watch Russian propaganda run about
him where they say hey Bernie is Putin's
favorite to win and then they come out
at 24 hours later and they say well okay
like that's not necessarily true but the
story got out already
yeah you think that affects primary
votes yeah I think so especially when
you stoke up a bunch of [ __ ] DNC
voters to think that Russia's some some
huge enemy that has [ __ ] us even
though they they what gave $100,000
maybe to [ __ ] over our elections
meanwhile Mike Bloomberg gave four
hundred million dollars and it didn't
affect one [ __ ] single vote nobody
puts us [ __ ] together it goes isn't this
weird out Russia [ __ ] our election
last time by putting a hundred grand in
which is what Facebook said they were in
Congress they said that [ __ ] and then
we're supposed to go Mike Bloomberg got
one delegate or what did he get [ __ ]
30 delegates or something small nothing
when one state basically okay how is he
able to win or not win that much what
four in a million dollars but Russia was
able to [ __ ] our whole election with a
hundred grand
guess what that's not what happened it's
not accurate [ __ ] like rendition of
what happened in 2016
Hillary never went to Wisconsin she
barely went to Pennsylvania and that's
what happened she lost deal with it she
but but the CIA the FBI all these guys
who were down with the Iraq war all this
[ __ ] they couldn't wait to put a
narrative a false narrative in the media
to try to [ __ ] over the Trump support
because Trump support in my opinion
Trump's support and Bernie supports like
a Venn diagram like I don't agree with
status quo I think this has both [ __ ]
so I want to go to somewhere extreme to
put my vote so that somebody will listen
to me okay and so you have Trump on the
right and yeah Bernie on the left and to
me as long as they're anti-war it's good
enough for me because I don't wanna I
don't want these pro war [ __ ] people
coming in [ __ ] up places like Libya
where there's open slave trading that
true Biden voted the Iraq war Biden was
very poor
or you could look up speeches of him
talking about the Iraq war he actually
just recently came out in the new
campaign he was talking to somebody on
CNN I was on MSNBC and he was talking to
his cat and he's like I only voted to
the Iraq war because I wanted to find
out what was really going on oh my god
you can look at the speeches of bight
talking about the Iraq war saying what
year was this well which one oh these
speeches you're talking about his recent
this is no so so this one is him talking
to an MSNBC guy I can't remember his
name upside my head but it's not Chris
Matthews was the only guy I know in
there but but it's it's the year that he
was talking about the Iraq war was when
it was like 2002 2003 and then you can
see you can see videos of old Biden
talking about how he voted for the Iraq
war and if you disagree with that then
[ __ ] you basically like he was very Pro
Iraq war and so was everyone at the time
George Bush Dick Cheney all those [ __ ]
although in the intelligence community
the intelligence community by the way
worldwide who all lied to get us into
the wars so that's what we're all saying
is I'm trust these [ __ ] people
anymore by the way the FBI was following
the 9/11 hijackers they actually had
agents who were on the case who were
watching these guys they never picked
them up never did anything the 9/11
hijackers were able to do what they did
why would the FBI even following them
that
so a lot of people are like I don't
trust our intelligence community I don't
trust our government who told us rush in
collusion all this [ __ ] and they use
it against people like Tulsi Gabbard
like honest people like Bernie Sanders I
think who are trying to affect change in
our government in our world they get
called 'russian polluters and poop
putin's puppets just like trump did
because if you're a political enemy of
the FBI CIA establishment types then
that's how they destroy you
it's just by saying hey you're one of
those enemies just like what happened
with the Red Scare where if you're an
actor in Hollywood and they say you
might be communist or sympathetic that's
the communism then you're communist and
so nobody's gonna watch your movie
anymore and your careers over overnight
in Blackley yeah are there anyone is
there anyone on the Republican side that
is kind of like the DNC where like their
Pro Ward yeah every single one of them
yeah every single one of them but it
Trump's warding them off basically I
don't know yet I don't know yet because
Trump seems okay with what's going on in
Yemen true with Saudi Arabia so I don't
know yet so at least Trump is the first
president in my lifetime and well not in
my lifetime he's the first president
since I've been an adult who has not
initiated a war that but that's a pretty
rough stance started the roughest
standard I've ever heard of right so I'm
not excited about that right that
doesn't excite me I just I think that
Bernie wouldn't have started another
work is all I think that somebody like
that who maybe has ostentatious ideas
that people like what's that's in fact
it looks crazy whatever like Trump at
least they're not gonna try to [ __ ]
start to start another war in Middle
East
you know when Bill Clinton said the
house of cards the show house of cards
wasn't too far off from the truth that
was like me telling you know depressing
yeah it's depressing man this is a
depressing it's a depressing [ __ ]
game politics it is I'm look at Bernie
Sanders right what does he do during the
Democrat debates
instead of calling out Joe Biden saying
hey you're owned by the credit card
companies hey
the reason why a lot of people are in
debt is because of Barclays because of
all these companies who have run up
these huge [ __ ] credit card debts
with all these people and they get paid
a certain amount every one
and since saying all that he goes you
know my friend Joe Biden who's a good
guy
I just happen to have different opinions
my friend Joe Biden instead of saying
that's what he's saying
my advice bring that game plan to a
debate well hey how about how about the
fact that in the debate you've got a
bunch of people applauding for certain
things that Joe Biden says which might
as well Joe Biden might as well be up
there and people like yeah that's a good
point and then and then Bernie's not
going like hey you know who's just glad
the lobbyists all the [ __ ] people
from the health care industry who are
here like he'd never done any of that
[ __ ] that's what's crazy
I paid $12,000 because me and Nicki paid
twelve that's nice because I had a
kidney stone
$12,000 imagine if I had something more
serious and I was with health insurance
imagine and the MAGIX hundred dollars a
month out the shirt my buddies old man
just got diagnosed with with prostate
cancer and he's got to go get treated
Durning corona talk about being [ __ ]
[Music]